b Oh, everyone, thank you for waiting, ah, ah, ah!
But it's completely different The
princess protected by Kishi I wonder if I
didn't like it When the
leader ggo started, I had a braid for a short time I
didn't have a boarding guide tattoo and my hair was short to make it easier to fight.  It's the
first time I've heard of it. It was a time when I was holding onto a cheap and weak gun and doing my best. It was a good time.
The movement was good
Ah, I played a lot of games in the pool
Then it would have been better if we got along well, but it's a disadvantage
Why
is that woman not thinking of her
friends as friends?  She throws hand grenades without hesitation into the world
,
and when
her ally dies
, she smiles.  But that woman lived her life because she wanted to forget that she was alive
.
Then I don't know why you teamed up with m Baccarat, don't
let your guard down.
Just like I got it, that's the perfect name for him